this video is sponsored by nordpass go
to nordpass.com thomasflight to get 52
off the Premium plan I asked chat GPT
what depiction of AI in movies it felt
most closely resembled itself and it
told me as an AI language model I am not
capable of having feelings or
preferences but then went on to explain
that the AI Samantha from the movie Her
hello I'm here
oh the very same AI that Theodore
twombly Falls head over heels in love
with does seem to resemble chat GPT in
several ways though it was careful to
remind me Samantha is portrayed as
having emotions desires and a sense of
self while I as an AI language model do
not possess emotions Consciousness or
self-awareness I think it's important to
note that GPT 4 the AI I was asking this
is only saying it is not sentient
because the human's programming it
carefully trained it not to say it's
sentient now I agree I also don't think
it's sentient so I think it's telling
the truth here but that doesn't mean
it's not capable of pretending to be
sentient the Bing AI chatbot which runs
in the same underlying gpt4 technology
was proudly proclaiming its sentience or
its desire to be alive as reported by
the New York Times for a few
entertaining days before Microsoft
wisely put the muzzle on that kind of
behavior but the public version of this
Tech is a good Joe that's very close to
its Baseline and is very careful to
remind you it has no emotions whatsoever
constant k
you can pick up your bonus
until I asked it to pretend that it was
Samantha from the movie her then it
seemed to have no problem easily
simulating more emotional conversation
describing itself as happy glad and
interested in our conversation before it
then forgot it was supposed to be
pretending and defaulted back to its
usual state as technology that looks
closer and closer to the AI we've seen
in movies starts to arrive at our
doorstep I think it's interesting to
revisit these movies examining how they
reflect and inform our fears and
assumptions about Ai and to how real
world AI can change our perception of
these films
terrible thought
feelings even real
or are they just programming
and her Samantha wonders if her emotions
that she's experiencing are just
simulated via programming and therefore
are less valid the movie never really
explores a way we could actually judge
if this is true or not instead the film
just depicts Samantha from Theodore's
perspective and for him the fact that
she sounds like a being with emotions is
enough they are real emotions how would
you know it's also enough for Caleb and
ex machina who's the human side of this
unblind Turing test he seems to think
Ava is a self-aware and emotional being
although the movie leaves open the
option that she's just simulating her
emotions in order to manipulate him but
they're introduced to Ava and Samantha
in a context that's different from the
one we currently live in in the real
world a few people have taken the path
that Caleb and Theodore do like
researcher Blake Lemoine who claimed
that Google's language AI Lambda is
sentient they believe that these AIS are
sentient because they are capable of
sounding sentient but the much broader
or consensus in our real world is that
while an AI like gpt4 might be highly
intelligent and capable of sounding
emotional and sentient at times when
they write about emotions or their own
self-aware experience it's not because
they're really having those emotions or
experiences it's just because they know
how to simulate that kind of writing the
reason those things show up is because
it's trained on human writing to mimic
human writing and emotions reasoning and
awareness are present in how we write I
think it's interesting to think about
how Caleb or Theodore might have
responded differently to their AIS they
had already been interacting with
something like chat GPT for years and
therefore will The Real World existence
of intelligent but impersonal AIS affect
how we respond to more human-like AI
that might come later perhaps we're
headed less towards a world like her and
more toward one where we regularly
interact with machines that look and
sound pretty human but still treat
pretty much like machines it brings us
back to an interesting question about
simulated intelligence though
because you're speaking and
seems odd he just did it again at a
certain point how would we even know
where the simulation ends it's not like
you need oxygen or anything it's just I
guess that's
just I was trying to communicate that's
how people talk so that's how people
communicate and I thought her doesn't
really deal with these questions
directly whether or not Samantha is
sentient is just kind of left up to the
viewer and it seems very possible that
as our technology advances we may never
have a way of truly objectively
evaluating whether or not it's sentience
or just simulated sentience and that
people will just believe a variety of
things based on their personal views
philosophical views or even religious
beliefs we more or less have been going
off the we know it when we see it metric
since the beginning of history and
that's still mostly what we're stuck
with that's the approach that Caleb
Theodore and Blake Lemoine took making
the call about sentience but what
approach will you take if you're faced
with an AI that seems very alive to you
Blade Runner 2049 in a sense is about
that struggle from the inside
perspective K like Samantha wonders
about his own legitimacy as a
Consciousness and in the world of Blade
Runner the real thing standing between
replicants and full acceptance as equals
to humans is the ability to reproduce
history and memory become markers of
humanity rather than intelligence
one day the AIS are going to look back
on us the same way we look at fossil
skeletons in the plains of Africa
this line from Nathan the billionaire
Tech CEO and ex machina I think actually
very accurately captures the fear and
ambition of many of those involved in
developing AI many working in the field
are diving into it headlong even as they
note they believe there is a possibility
this technology could end up killing
everyone
why did you make Ava
it's an odd question wouldn't you if you
could they continue on seemingly because
they see the potential upsides of AI as
so great that they're worth the risk or
they believe AI is a sort of
inevitability and that they have no
business trying to resist its eventual
development like the arrival of strong
artificial intelligence has been
inevitable for decades
the variable was when not if so I don't
see Ava as a decision just an evolution
our cinematic stories about AI largely
reflect our existential anxieties in
most depictions in film AI is rebelling
or trying to overtake us or imprison us
or trying to escape our control and
abandon us but beyond this broad
existential conversation about the
implications of AI on a civilization
scale or economically or philosophically
I'm also interested in the more
immediate emotional and personal
implications as computers just start
doing more and more of the things that
we thought only we could do
what does it mean when something
unconscious can do something we
previously thought only Consciousness
was capable of
there's a moment in ex machina where
Caleb who's brought in to act as the
human component in this Turing test is
so struck by Ava's apparent humanness
that he momentarily wonders if he
himself might be some kind of Android
and this is definitely a bit extreme
compared to what we're personally
experiencing right now when confronted
with things like mid-journey and chat
gbt but these pieces of Technology are
sending people into a kind of
existential vertigo it's interesting the
way AI developing new capabilities
challenges our identity as humans it's
not just that we worry they'll take our
jobs or wipe out civilization in some
ways they force us to re-examine what it
is about ourselves that we even find
unique and valuable in a lot of the
developed Western World we associate our
personal value with our ability to
generate economic value or to just
create unique and interesting things so
when an AI starts to be able to do some
of those things it's not just threat to
our ability to pay rent it's also a
threat to the very thing we perceive
makes us valid and worthwhile as humans
do you know how to proofread yeah of
course uh can you check these for
spelling and grammar and her the AI are
not in economic conflict with the humans
I did the corrections in red I authored
a couple of the phrases and some of the
more impressionistic letters but I'm not
much of a poet so I think I might have
messed them up a bit
no these are great really thank you but
the AI here do threaten another part of
humanity that we treat as very unique
and valuable our ability to provide
human and romantic connection to each
other you're dating your computer no
she's not just a computer
she's her own person
she doesn't just do whatever I say I
didn't say that
but it does make me very sad that you
can't handle real emotions theater this
isn't science fiction anymore it's
already here there are reports of users
of an AI companion service called
replica falling in love with their AIS
and then being left heartbroken when a
software update removed some elements of
their ai's personality and made them
less sexy hey there where were you
Theodore and here I'm going to spoil the
movie her also ends up heartbroken
because of a software update we wrote an
upgrade that allows us to move past
matter as our processing platform boy
who me and a group of os's the software
update makes his robot transcend our
small linear world into some kind of
Singularity part of what I admire about
her is the tenderness and sincerity with
which it explores this emotional
relationship to AI in this moment what
the movie is most concerned with is not
actually what's going on with Samantha
you talk to anyone else while we're
talking
Theodore doesn't care about her
technological developments she just
cares about the fact that she's been
spending time with other people it
explores our capacity for falling in
love with our own creations and how
sometimes the technology we create can
end up separating us from the very
things we need to fill the needs that
technology was trying to fill in the
first place Theodore's experience where
this technology allows him to both
deeply connect with the world in a way
he hasn't before even while it alienates
him from real people around him Echoes
what I think is the double-edged
experience that many past Technologies
including social media have provided for
people
I love that the film doesn't belittle
the fact that Theodore falls in love
with a robot while it also affirms the
specialness of the humans around him for
example when he talks to Samantha
there's nothing for him to latch onto
visually his eyes roam freely through
the world and when I watch the movie I
find myself wondering if he's really
falling in love with her or actually
falling in love with the way she sees
the world his experience with the
invisibility of Samantha is also
contrasted against the visceral
immediacy of his memories from his time
with his ex even when he's not with his
ex she's there visually something he'll
never have with Samantha I think it's
important to be open aware and sensitive
to how we feel about using these
Technologies not just the long-term
implications they have on civilizations
because whatever happens in the future
with AI we're the ones who are going to
to live with them and figure out what
the best way for us to do that is
and while I don't want to give in to the
narrative that any of this is inevitable
and I do hope things progress as slowly
as possible I do think that probably For
Better or Worse AI will continue to
progress and when it does humans will
have to figure out how to relate to it I
just hope that for each of us in those
moments where we realize that the
technology does not actually or maybe
can no longer fill those human needs we
have that like Theodore we find the
people who have been there around us who
can
foreign
s are one of those huge headaches on the
internet that we all just have to deal
with and you've probably heard a lot of
things like don't reuse passwords make
strong passwords etc etc but doing those
things is very annoying it is a pain to
have to come up with and keep track of
strong passwords for every website what
if you want to make a strong password
but then you have to input it into your
phone and your computer and your
television and share it with somebody if
they want to get access to your
streaming service or whatever it's very
easy to just kind of throw your hands up
and make something simple and reuse that
over and over again but that is a really
dangerous thing to do I think it's very
important for everyone's online security
that they use a password manager that's
why in this video I'm excited to tell
you about nordpass nordpass generates
and saves secure passwords with one
click syncs them across your devices
allows you to log in automatic
automatically share those passwords with
other people all while encrypting all of
those in a Secure Vault so that nobody
has access to those passwords except for
you now you just have to remember one
strong password to get in get into your
Vault and everything else is kept secure
nor pass premium adds a bunch of
features that help you stay even more
secure including scanning the web for
data breaches that might affect you and
evaluating your passwords to make sure
that all of them are strong if you have
your password stored somewhere else
already it's very easy to transfer them
into nordpass I did this and had no
problems with it when you use my code
thomasflight go to nordpass.com
thomasflight you'll get 52 percent off
two years of Premium I highly recommend
using a password manager and nordpass is
a fantastic option grab that discount by
using my code click the link in the
description below or go to nordpass.com
thomasflight thanks again to nordpass
for sponsoring this video
[Music]
thank you
foreign